uh all right so you do a 180 you turn
your life around yeah because you have
this conversation with your mom I do
that your dad so what happens what you
just become a good poster child for uh
don't do drugs so I went to a new school
and then I joined a new hockey team so I
was 14 playing on a junior uh hockey
team most of the guys on the team were
20 21.
um really yeah 19 to 21. 19 20 21 was
like and you're 14. I was 14 I remember
my first day everyone was talking about
this guy Brian Suey Brian Suey he just
got out of jail he's our fighter and I'm
like what the [ __ ] I'm 14. so these guys
just got out of jail oh you do did just
deal yeah you're not like Joe you're
right so I get to the rink and we have a
um a preseason game the first shift this
kid goes out and fights three people
he's insane and I'm like this league is
crazy and it was like such an
eye-opening experience I'm like holy
were you like I gotta get out of here no
no no I loved it because I was [ __ ]
crazy like that I mean I was a by the
time I was 15 I was fighting everyone in
the league and that was fighting 20 year
olds so wow you are you're Fearless yeah
in that sense like I I was and by the
time I got there I was like I was the
fighter but by the way there's something
to be said about wearing all that
equipment having a helmet having all
these things and you get in a fight
you're thinking I'm padded mostly yeah
you know people think it's so gross some
in this and you punch in the face and
stuff but you are protected in a lot of
ways and they're going to break it up I
mean not in that League uh they let him
fight yeah fighting was it was it's
Junior so fighting's five minute
fighting you take your helmets and
gloves off and these guys would just go
at it and I was I came from youth hockey
so that was my next year I was like oh
my God but then once I was there for
like a month I was like okay this is
like second nature you know you were
playing with the big boys and you're
doing well are you scoring I'm doing
well uh I don't think I played every
game that season I think I got I think I
only got scratched from like four games
because we were playing there was this
team that I never played against because
it was all 21 year old Fighters right
and the coach was like I'm just not
gonna play him because it's just not
worth it
um so but I had a good year like that
was my one of my best years of hockey
and then the following year was another
one of my best years and that's when I
got drafted in the Quebec Junior Hockey
League